Oh Glenn cab exclusive where this is
mike posner and you are locked in with
the best [__] radio DJ in the world
who let cat yo ty 975 bootleg keV live
in studio my do mike posner well where
the what up keV man so you have a single
the first single for the new album once
you tell me what's name of new album sky
high sky high and looks like sex is is
that is the joint luzerne so I'm hearing
from from from good sources that big
sean might be on your first or your next
single you heard that from big sean its
wife stuff from good sources haha it was
a double entendre can you confirm oh
yeah yeah uh well i can i can confirm
he's on that song pretty sure it's gonna
be the next single possibly the is he's
gonna be on the album though he's a meal
known for sure which is awesome he's on
the song i can confirm that ok cool
could you tell us the name of the song
top of the world top of the world that's
what's up yeah can't wait to hear it me
the new music is super incredible like
the people i've been playing it for just
like flipping out um so uh pharrell's on
the album like i did like nine joint so
far oh I know you're you were in the
studio with Pharrell you were in the
studio with weezer yes yes well they're
not on the house Jesus Cole oh really j
cole's on the album yeah that's dope
dude did you guys record this all
together like what's he do ya know I
went to New York and we worked on the
beat together and nice and did the joint
together wrote it together how was it
producing a song with j Cole it was
incredible on that try it was a track he
had started so he had done like the most
of the beef for sure and I kinda just
added stuff to it but man was amazing
working on him like working with him and
Sean like back to back it was like the
level of talent it was just so
incredible both those guys are so
different in a lot of ways but but I
think just like their genius level ours
is like really up there and then close
new music is incredible to hear some
isaac sir yeah
what is the release date oh haven't yet
okay I'm not quite done you're not done
yet no most people they put single out
and as you know the valves already in
the can yeah well you know sometimes
like do so differently care just like so
you know the trail blazer over here no I
mean Sarge I baby mmm I think probably
later than that really yeah my Prada
nother single and let that live and then
September you were drunk last night i
was super wasted in phoenix arizona last
night Kevin and I were both in Phoenix
our friend Lady laws birthday party I
was very intoxicated and we're not Kevin
went in well the thing is we're gonna
party tonight tonight so I was saving up
and kev I'm he blew his load early my
load last night you're gonna be drunk
tonight and I'm gonna be having a Dasani
see what happens ladies fiji on deck um
10 finishes early lady oh my goodness um
I don't FYI stow that in there um we
we're gonna be waiting a while for the
album which kind of sucks for the fans
of your music like myself but hey the
mixtape man was crazy dude thank you so
much do I think that's your best mixtape
I think so too like I really so too you
know I know a lot what's the record on
there were you kind of talking about um
what's it called I'm kind of like on
your door I'm not we're talking to your
fans are thinking this yeah like I'm not
I'm not your secret anymore hmm how was
that man coming up from like the mixtape
scene and you're kind of like you know
which is kind of what I feel like a lot
of the people who are running hip-hop
and you know music in general um they
came up kind of similar aspects where
you know they were kind of the cool
nobody knows about him like that yet
they haven't blown up yet not had a very
like you know kind of cult following a
very you know cool fan base it and then
you started playing some it was your
fault and then you blew up so I mean I
know you probably hear my poster sold
out or you know dude how do you deal
with like deal with that criticism like
you know what do you want me to do man
you want me to just be underground
forever thank you good I gotta matter to
be frustrating like you can't make
anybody happy well yes is for
streaming here here that sometimes but
the only thing I can do is keep being
better but I don't like like you said
that's my best mixtape yet definitely um
and like my beats on another level now
my vocals on another level now so you
know so that's all I can do is keep
progressing and keep making stuff that
that if I were to die today wouldn't
wouldn't not exist you know I'm saying
try to make music that that only already
make way to verities no songs bro gotta
let me hear some stuff tonight about to
run off to read to stop toying and stop
recording yeah um dude hahahaha so uh
you did the stay scheming cover yeah
which was awesome thanks bro um you be
when you do a cover because you know
you've covered quite a few records
lately um I'm not even gonna front the
Adele joint that you covered I don't
need it because I I never heard the
original I wasn't like a funny man come
on no no listen to me heard the original
no no when you put it out like it hadn't
blown up like that like it was big but
it wasn't like yeah everywhere and like
I'm I'm kind of like I don't I'm kind of
I won't necessarily close minded but
something like really gotta like come to
me like something like that for me to I
really pay attention to that's not
hip-hop stuff exactly so like when I
heard the cover I was the first time I
heard the actual song I was like yo [__]
is crazy oh man let's love that's love
that's really what I try to kind of do
is like when I do a song like that like
another one I did it with this rocket
man by a long john kill the coldplay
Jory yeah thank you would I try to do
with those ones that are like really
kind of sappy songs right that let Kevin
normally like is make them as ghetto
hip-hop as possible with but beyond rock
with the production exactly so like
there's no other wall would be great
yeah there's no other person is going to
put a big krit on an oasis song or or
bun b on Ellen jaan songs so that's why
I try to do is like flip flip these
things in like it's did you receive any
flack for for covering such classics
because you know some people feel like
oh man Elton John a timeless music
nobody should touch it yes some people
say I mean anytime you you're messing
with this song that's like great and I
song right people are going to say that
some people
aren't going like it as much of the
original because they're so attached to
originally before they even here it's no
way already but I think a lot of people
like this nike like yourself like maybe
fall in love with the original after
because of me you know yeah so breakdown
in the in the scientist we're sitting
and then a stash it goes hard thank you
brother yeah I'm really proud of that
beat that I did good on yo that'd be
crazy oh my goodness holla atlas rappers
oh yeah that was askew man like with the
production you're such a great producer
and and on your mixtape you produce most
everything on there right yeah so that
was a question you asked me last songs
he was like why you never make beats for
other people so what is going on with it
i I've been stepping it up lately I uh I
have Bieber's new single you joke I
wrote and produced that man really yeah
that's pretty major yes what's up and
wait till you hear to be Roy you're a
flip like you don't want to play this
song really yes is super his night I had
I had Bieber on my show and he freaked
out over a shot you and and then I
listen listen it was funny because
though no he was he was he did his thing
but I had like death threats on Twitter
cuz of that why cuz i had Justin Bieber
rap on a biggie beep he wanted to kill
me man I could see that he raps like a
like little eight bars and then start
singing crazy right after it sounds
amazing she was amazing so I'm looking
forward to that man yo wait you guys
that you like the new Bieber I've been
working on this project like worked on
with like Timbaland me and he was
talking to him and I was like yo when
are you gonna make that turn that turn
that Justin Timberlake made where you
know timber that used to be corny and
then he started making music we got
older now that we can he's million now
myself a 25 year old grown-ass man that
doesn't wanna drive around listening to
bieber can be like oh you know what you
gonna get slapped like you're going like
that was our whole goal was like to make
something that was hater proof and as I
did I like me and Big Sean Tucker llama
it was to make stuff that like guys like
Mike posing boo like keV hate on could
put in the car with their friends and be
like you know what spirit is dope I
can't hate sorry so that's that's
what is it is like a workout the crazy I
mean what's it like working with him
yeah he's incredibly super talented like
at first I didn't really know what to
expect because he's so young young and
but Duke can write and and really like
that even timblin was I yo he's alright
I know so he's super dope and I can't
wait for that then new stuff I can't
wait that's that's good your is a tapper
you see you're supposed to talk about
that right now recipe was gonna send you
a text message for this interview comes
out no I'm a lot of talking about that I
rely to talk about yeah hey the Biebs I
same things I mean did I no no I'm
saying I'm really exposing his salt his
album stuff you know I'm saying is dope
oh man so album coming out hopefully
around September yes um you're gonna
hold off on putting a single out a
little bit DeSean was second second
whatever second single you decide to
choose because I see light looks like
sex and do as well is it it showed done
radio wise yes wait see here the new
direction oh the new direction of the
house um credible the stuff you let me
hear about six seven months ago is is
that stuff so gonna be like at the I'm
no idea what I played you to be honest
the toast record yeah that'll probably
be the intro that's my [__] right there
i'll probably the intro yes i can't wait
man so might they also get a feature on
it man no all right i think i think if
you already have Jake Owen big sean on
the album I think I think that's I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get another feature
can't say who it is yet okay I'm sorry
for doodling darkness interviewed a
little bit up dude um can you tell me
about dope my drawing is Raina I wanted
to ask you because since we're not live
on the air we can talk about something
pop [__] he reported what is your
favorite hip-hop album of all time is it
a crime and I okay that's what I thought
you're gonna say did you already know
that I I you know what I think I I
thought I was either gonna be a criminai
or nas album we've kind of comes to boys
kind of guy kind of he kind of i forgot
what album we were talking about with
nas and you're like once I heard that I
just had I put him second place to
outcast what
okay yeah no comment no I love not it's
not like I'm the biggest nice guy have
all the records automatic was definitely
my number one for a long time and then I
think I saw her smoking more weed and
equipment i became like the one is
because that album was so incredibly
ahead of his time like like half the
songs on there have real drums you know
I me and like there's no programming on
that and like okay that doesn't sound
that crazy but back then like what year
was that 98 98 like four legged hip hop
group to dude I was insane and I mean
like this stuff was so ahead of his time
even like 80 there atliens like we put
that on now and that production it
sounds like it was made yesterday yeah
all right yeah like we put on 2dopeboyz
and atliens and like those songs are so
our time and they are literally not
exaggerating 15 years old and they sound
like they were made yesterday or
tomorrow exactly uh the brain trust
thing man what can you explain the
concept behind that I know it's kind of
like the clicked uh yeah movement yeah
so when I first started I was in a band
it's called Mike Posner in the brain
trust and the band quit okay and so now
I called it like the fans and the people
that support me to brain trust I want to
walk on the stage everyone puts their
brain so it brings up and there's people
who the original brain trust that quit
do they feel stupid no they're doing
good they're doing good i'm i'm still
cool with them and I as you go man
nothing big I think one of them really
will might do better than me one day
okay sorry there was a time to do so I'm
not mad at them like that they just want
to want to want to like really do their
own thing okay and I think he will kill
it monday seems eric whole gist Eric
Holder super not hip-hop but maybe you
like it is how far you think do serve
all eternity man all the way all the way
to go championship man i was at i went
back for the unc game you did it was
terrible harbor
awful wait didn't didn't didn't rivers
hit hit a shot to know that was the last
time I was last time now that you and
see like a month ago okay and then there
no game at Duke and he could go all get
and do n Duke did lose again they got
smacked it was embarrassing but I got
trashed after the game to make up for it
like I was like bawling like a all star
pretending I was a sophomore hey you
like walk through the Duke campus like
yeah dude I but she was like of Duke
like legend they're like they'd probably
tell stories about the [__] that went
down with my potion what today are you
that guy like that threw parties and may
I was in the dorm like maybe no man I
was did you not hear my mixtapes that's
what that's what I was doing yeah that's
what I was doing my people you say thing
I was like kind of weird because I was
spent so much time in my room and my
friends used to like like I remember
when I turned 21 it was a Saturday and
my friends are like banging on my door I
had my door locked yeah they breed like
I knew they were gonna try to do it I
just locked the door because I was
working on a matter of time and they
were like we don't even know where
mixtape is broke what the [__] is that
no one has a cassette player no more
like you stupid how are we supposed to
listen to it idiot that's crazy I
brightway man thank you for coming
through for the interview brother thank
you for having me you know as a pleasure
this is this is the best radio
personality ever I appreciate that and
you are the best artist ever that is a
real hand they don't know what they
don't know your tumblr you explain it
yeah let me see the camera I've been
I've been doodling look at this doodle
this one I messed up though we were
talking about somethin weird yes like
yeah that's like a mechanic's hand
[__] up fingernail now it can make it
goth if we do their nails black